Germany has decided in principle to buy
F-35 fighter jets from the U.S that's
according to new reports citing
government sources now Berlin plans to
drastically beef up military spending as
a result of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine it's not alone Denmark and
Sweden say they're also raising their
military spending over the coming years
now traditionally larger Nations have
spent moral defense in 2020 the U.S with
a whopping 770 80 billion dollars
budgeted for defense China only 252
billion dollars on its military but that
still dwarfs Germany with 53 billion
euros or dollars I should say now that
year Russia had a military budget of 62
billion dollars that's 10 times what
Ukraine spent and while it seems much
smaller than China or the US it
represents a greater share of the
Russian economy
so which companies are the biggest
players in defense well U.S company
Lockheed Martin makes the F-35
is one of that's one of the largest in
the industry with sales of 66 billion
dollars last year it's followed by
Europe's Airbus and two more U.S
companies Raytheon Technologies and
Boeing
now the Stockholm International Peace
Research Institute tracks military
expenditures around the world I asked
their senior researcher Lucy barod Sutro
to put recent events into perspective
we are seeing at the moment
um strong announcements all across
Europe in particular for increased
military expenditure but also in Canada
which is also a NATO member and of
course countries are reacting uh to the
outbreak of the war in Ukraine
um and countries have are actually
now making decisions to increase the
dormitory expenditure and reaching the
two percent Target set by NATO something
they have been asked to do since 2014
but are now really making a move towards
one of those countries of course Germany
announcing that it wants to stay with
the two percent of GDP
um level for defense expenditures so are
we saying that we're seeing more
countries that are spending that haven't
traditionally spent as much in the past
is that fair to say or is it more The
Usual Suspects China the U.S Russia
population of the trend input here in
Europe
um so European countries had been
already increasing their military
expenditure for the past few years in
particularly since 2014 in Russia's
annexation of Crimea but this trend is
actually accelerating so there were
increases that had been announced but
now there are increased on top of
increases so to speak
so countries let's say for instance like
Sweden or Poland we're already saying
that we're going to increase
inflammatory expenditure but not least
they're going to increase even more so
we're going to see Europe as one of the
really the key regions driving military
spending forward in the coming years
not just the usual suspects as you were
mentioning
can we say what kinds of spending we're
seeing is this for modernizing programs
for modernizations is it for new weapon
systems can you can you break it down a
little bit more
it's too early to say because really we
are really just at the stage of
announcements so a country is promising
they're going to increase spending to
two percent or more put on is even
saying they're going to go to three
percent
Germany says more than two percent so um
but really at this stage we don't know
yet there are just been a few
announcements um I think we're
mentioning the F-35 for Germany
um but it's really too early to tell I
think one key question when it comes to
Europe or NATO as a whole is how to
coordinate all those increases there are
going to be billions of uh Euros or
dollars going to the normalization of
armed forces but how to make sure this
is done in a coordinated fashion that we
don't duplicate
um when we don't you know waste money in
the process I think there will be a
really strong role for NATO and the EU
in making sure that this is done in a
coordinated fashion